[Music]
we are joined by some of our colleagues
from financial aid and so this is our
chance to really talk about that and so
Elizabeth can you please introduce
yourself and tell us a little bit about
your role
hi everyone yeah my name is Elizabeth
yamas I am the associate director of
financial aid here at the GSB very
excited to be joining you this morning
so I work with all students veterans
everyone to help them through the
financial aid process and then also
support you while you're a student with
the GSB cool so can you tell us a little
bit about what's financial aid like at
the GS you what's the process sure so
for you know most students we've built a
system around three principles guiding
principles that we want to instill in
our process excellence access and
fairness and so when we talk about
financial aid we do have a combination
in general of fellowship and loans and
we're looking at a student's income and
assets which is you know very if you've
been through a financial aid process
before which some of you may have this
is probably very similar something that
you're familiar with we have as far as
the process goes we have our own
financial aid portal for our students so
it's a one-stop shop portal for you
that's customized to your situation and
it's a great tool for our students to
connect with our office but also to
submit everything to us very securely so
very excited about it cool and then um
knowing our audience today can you tell
us a little bit more about opportunities
for veterans and especially make you
touch on the Yellow Ribbon Program
please definitely that's probably
chapter 33 post-911 yellow ribbon is
definitely one of the most common VA
benefits that we have at the GSB and so
for those who are
maybe looking to use their Yellow Ribbon
benefits for the first time essentially
once you're eligible and you receive
your certificate of eligibility you'll
have 36 months our program is built
around a nine-month financial aid budget
so you'll be using about eighteen months
for the two years of your benefit and
Stanford is committed to supporting our
Yellow Ribbon veterans as much as
possible so our match with the VA
funding will cover up to your tuition so
that's a really great thing for our
veterans that they don't have to worry
about the tuition costs for those who
maybe are not yellow ribbon eligible we
still have like I said other methods of
financial aid to help support you as
well cool and then what about folks who
might be interested in like like the
nonprofit or government yeah so yeah we
have a and I think I know where you're
going with this we have a really awesome
loan forgiveness program if you do find
that you need to borrow loans to help
supplement your educational costs and so
that's for students who are looking to
go back into a government sector or
possibly into the nonprofit sector this
program has been around at the GSB for a
very long time so over ten years it's a
well established program it is our own
it's completely independent from the
government's loan forgiveness program
and if you do enter into one of these
sectors essentially if we will help you
assist you repay your loan balances as
an alumni so it's a really great
opportunity for those who are thinking
about going back into the nonprofit or
public sector and then as I'm thinking
about financial aid like prospector app
applicant like do you have any like tips
best practices things that we should be
keeping in the back of our mind as we're
going through the journey
definitely so um Stanford's been really
has their own veteran's department I'm
not sure if you've already touched on
that in the past Jen okay
so we weren't hand in hand with Omak so
it's really important you know as you
start to get this information that
you're not only in communication with us
but we will also help you assist you
with the communication with Omak and
come together the earlier you can get
your documentation ready the better so
that's going through whatever be a
process that you need - especially
getting that Certificate of Eligibility
and so if you need assistance as far as
like the next steps we definitely ask
that you reach out to us or to the Omak
our colleagues at Omak to assist you
with that process but other than that
you know we're here to support you so if
you're a minute you will walk you
through the necessary steps to apply for
financial aid cool
so the Omak that we were referred to a
couple of times is the office for
military affiliated communities at
Stanford University and this is not just
a GSB organization but one that helps
support our veterans across our whole
community both the undergrads and the
different grad departments so once again
Omak is the office for military
affiliated communities yes and then
let's say I'm an admitted student I'm
like is there any way to kind of
understand like what I could be getting
is as a financial aid package yeah so
once you're admitted we do have a
calculator tool which we encourage all
students to use to get a better
understanding of what they may qualify
for before they begin the financial aid
process so that's that will be available
to you as an admitted student cool and
then one other thing knowing that kind
of from experience like what about
families like oftentimes we think about
hey I'm applying to business school as
like an individual but for many in many
of our applicants if there's either a
significant other or there's children
who are gonna be participating in this
journey like how does that factor in to
financial aid yeah so our cost of
attendance which is essentially the
budget for the program is built around
your circle
stances so if you're single or if you're
married and if you're married if you're
bringing any children or dependents with
you to the GSB so you know of course
those costs may increase for you for our
Yellow Ribbon recipients you are
eligible for ended housing allowance on
top of the tuition payment so you would
be receiving that monthly as well to
help offset those costs cool
thank you just covered a lot of ground
and depressive amount of time are there
any other things like from you like
having sat in your seat for so long any
any other words of wisdom or things that
you would love to share with the group
yeah I mean it's you know it can be
scary
approaching financial aid in general or
some for some people find it kind of
stressful you know the people in our
office my colleagues and myself we've
been doing this for a very long time and
I've also been a certifying official for
the VA so I know what you need to go
through to get your benefit and so my my
tip to everyone is just to start
conversations or as early as possible
with our office we're here to assist you
and we would love to help you walk
through this process and make sure that
you feel secure about your package and
and how you're gonna afford the GSB nice
all right so that's those are my
questions if you can't tell there's a
lot of joy in our office and these are
gonna extend that joy to the group um
we're gonna open it up right now are
there any general financial aid
questions or funding questions that
folks in the audience might have so feel
free to pop those into the Q&A box and
let's really make the most of our time
with one of our financial aid experts
again my hands are pointing in this
direction because that's where her
window is in my screen I don't know
where Elizabeth might be any horse agree
so that might be but this is the time to
ask see
questions here here's question from
Christophe when is the deposit for the
program typically do assuming like
you're admitted when do you have to make
that deposit yeah so the the deposit is
due and we'll jump in if I believe that
posit is due by the time that you accept
your admissions offer is that correct
right so it's due upfront as just for a
once you're admitted you'll have time to
receive your financial aid award really
weigh your options and then commit to
the program and accept your offer and
that's when your deposit is due I will
say for the VA with the VA benefits the
one thing that is not covered if your
post-911
eligible is a deposit for a program but
you're still fully covered for your
tuition and the deposit will go to
offset other costs of the university
great all right here's a question about
dual degree students Howard how's the GI
Bill and the Yellow Ribbon benefits
applied towards dual degree programs
yeah so essentially with a dual degree
program you're looking at a little bit
most likely a little bit longer than an
18-month program which is normal for an
MBA student so depending on the dual
degree that you're admitted to it could
be you know 24 months etc as long as
you're you know enrolled in an
educational program that your VA
benefits will continue to support your
education and so like I had mentioned
once you're eligible for yellow ribbon
you usually have if you have not used it
before 36 months of benefits so it's
quite a bit of time and we're only using
about 18 so if your enrollment extends
past that 18 months then you'll have
continued eligibility all right thank
you here's a really important question
from Carolyn if you do not qualify for
yellow ribbon due to partial GI bill are
there other financial aid programs or
scholarships that you recommend like
what did that exceed yeah so if you're
not eligible for
a chapter that covers your full-tuition
then we encourage you to apply for our
need-based fellowship program which is
what I talked about a little bit in the
beginning where we look at your income
and assets and we you know you go
through the process like a normal
student and that you know if your are
eligible for fellowship that can help
offset those additional costs that are
not covered by the VA
additionally we do have some resources
that you will have access to for
external scholarships and we definitely
encourage all of our students to look
for additional opportunities outside of
our office and we're also here to help
you with those opportunities so we have
a general list for you to work off of
but there could be more opportunities
than that for you
yeah and correct me if I'm wrong but
last year was in the average financial
aid package around $40,000 per year per
student yeah it was around $40,000 for
our students and that's per year so it's
you know it that can definitely help
supplement you know what the the VA is
giving you towards the tuition great
here's the question so the application
process we're need-blind in applications
so that means that how you're gonna
finance your time at the GSB has no
impact on the final decision so our
need-based process or our new our
financial aid process is need-based okay
so correct slip separation there for the
applications there's three rounds so
around one round two round three is
there a difference in financial aid
funding among the three rounds there's
definitely not we've committed that
whatever round that you're admitted to
the GSB n you will have the same
opportunity for financial aid as those
and round one and two versus three or
any combination of those so same
opportunity any round you apply for your
admitted you still have the financial
aid opportunities as everyone else
great and here's one a little bit about
housing so knowing that this financial
aid covers a lot of ground here is the
housing stipend you mentioned
with yellow ribbon different than or in
addition to the housing allowance
receive while using the GI bill did you
happen to know no it's the same so it's
it's the PAH housing allowance as part
of the GI Bill and it's good to be based
on Stanford zip code so if you're
interested you can head over to the VA
website our zip code is nine for 305 and
you can check out what your benefit
level will be with that bah housing
stipend great and then one question here
actually there's a couple questions
along this theme so need-based financial
aid can you talk a little bit more about
like what are a couple of the elements
on there and then is it based only on
those are like what happens if there's
something in my life is there capture
there yeah
so the initial application is going to
ask you for several years of income as
well as your assets and when we talk
about assets we are looking at liquid
and illiquid assets and then we always
leave you know we want to take a
holistic approach to your financial aid
package and so we're opening it up to if
you have circumstances that you think
impedes your ability to pay for your
education we definitely want to hear
about those in your applications so we
have an opportunity for you to explain
and you know if for some reason you have
extenuating medical expenses or possibly
or supporting your family you know we
want to know about those so there's an
opportunity for you to explain
situations outside of what we're asking
for all right so thank you again
Elizabeth for jumping on and helping
that was a lot of really helpful media
information and why were those who were
have been asking questions thank you for
your engagement if you didn't get your
questions answered live today we're
gonna continue answering some of them
over the course in the Q&A box as to the
best of our abilities also feel free to
jump on our website I keep referring
folks back to that yes it's gonna be one
of your best resources continue asking
us questions there we are here to
support you
along this process
[Music]